it's early morning in port-au-prince and
worshipers dressed in their sunday best
are on their way to church
[Music]
as a wave of violent crime grips the
city many are praying for divine
intervention against criminal gangs who
are fighting for control over haiti's
capital
religious leaders tell us even places of
worship have become a target for
kidnappers
we know we're a church that has been
exposed because we are right there on
the streets
a week ago they tried to kidnap a member
of our church by the grace of god she
ran so we all have been affected by what
is going on in the country
so far this year at least 40 church
members have been kidnapped in haiti
this includes 17 missionaries associated
with a us-based christian charity who
were abducted last weekend by a group
called 400 malozo one of the city's most
dangerous gangs
prayer services across town now count on
added security measures like barbed wire
fences and even metal detectors to
screen for danger
this street in downtown port-au-prince
leads to a church and on sunday mornings
security guards block off the exits
using motor vehicles and they keep a
close watch on everyone who crosses the
ropes the efforts are to prevent
kidnappers from driving up to the doors
of the church and abducting the pastor
in just the first eight months of the
year close to 800 people were kidnapped
in the country and the un is pointing to
another alarming trend a dramatic
increase in the number of women and
children being targeted
kidnappings can take place at any given
time of the day or the night and
anywhere it sometimes takes place at
home in the street at school or even in
churches so there is no safe space for
children
anymore and we really see that the
criminal gangs are using children
increasingly as bargaining chips
it's an increasingly lucrative business
in the hands of the criminal gangs
this man who has asked us to hide his
identity is a kidnapping survivor he
tells al jazeera that he still lives
with the trauma of the experience and
worries that it could happen again as
insecurity continues to grow i'm scared
right now for my son because they come
into the yard and pick up the person
inside your yard now right now i don't
have to take the car out for them to get
nothing
i don't have to take my car out to go
against nothing they could come in here
more than a hundred abductions have been
recorded in the country in october alone
haiti currently has the highest
kidnapping rate in the world per capita
many here say violence has grown beyond
the ability for authorities to control
and that the last place they have left
to find solace is in the mercy of god
manuel rapalo al-jazeera port-au-prince